ladies and gentlemen welcome to Sunday
morning science I am your host John
Perry I don't have a guest today
sometimes we have guests sometimes we
don't I'm actually I'm very excited
about today because I'm going to take
you on an internet Safari I'm going to
something that I do from time to time is
I will just get on get on the internet
start start doing start reading papers
start doing Google Image searches and
just learn about wildlife and this is
kind of actually how I've educated
myself in biology over the years I mean
I've studied biology in college but it
actually was not my focus and it's
amazing how how much information you can
glean by just kind of going down rabbit
hole after rabbit hole and asking more
questions digging a little bit deeper so
today's video is evolutionary oddities
misfits and living transitions and
before I start my slide show here that
I've prepared for you I wanted to this
week I made chocolate chip cookies and I
was thinking about the different
ingredients in a chocolate chip cookie
and how many species are in a chocolate
chip cookie and I just wanted to get
your guests without googling it how many
species do you think exists inside of a
chocolate chip cookie the normal
ingredients for a simple chocolate chip
cookie so if you can think about that
and write your comments in the in the
chat here here in well at the end of the
of today's show we'll talk about that in
in detail and I'll reveal the answer so
how many species are in a chocolate chip
cookie we'll talk about it about that at
the end but first
let's take a look at these these
organisms these crazy misfits of
evolution all right here we go there's
my slides so this first critter is a
really interesting one this is a three
toed yellow-bellied skink and this
species is native to Australia and
there's actually lots of skanks that
live in different parts of the world
really lots of them are in Australia I'm
not sure if that's where they originated
or
and then they dispersed I actually don't
know but the most common type of skank
and let me here's here's another picture
of the same species there's a there's an
adult and a juvenile down here in this
picture and you can see that they
actually have four legs but their legs
are tiny and well we'll talk about why
their legs are so small later but just
skanks in general no there's another
picture of it you can see that it's
called the three-toed skank because it
has three toes on each of its legs
they're the most common version are the
most common species of skank actually I
guess it's group of species of skank
would be the the blue tail or the blue
tongued skink and they're the most well
known because there you'll find them in
pet stores and we've done a lot of
selective breeding with them they come
in all sorts of colors and they're
called the blue tongued skink because
they have a blue tongue and they use it
to display supposedly this is
threatening when they when they stick
their tongue out it that's scary I don't
know why this works but somehow enough
organisms were scared of a lizard
sticking its tongue out that this trait
evolved and when this this animal is
threatened it will stick out its tongue
and try to scare you and I'm not sure if
the
evolved because it worked to scare
predators or if it evolved as signaling
between members of the same species it's
it's a threat to other members of the
same species but the males and the
females both have blue tongue so far as
I know correct me if I'm wrong but it's
oh we're getting some guesses on the on
the chocolate chip cookies how many
species there are in a chocolate chip
cookie we got 10 we got 42 good guess 42
anyway the blue tongued skink here's
another really beautiful picture of one
that's look at that tongue that is crazy
it's crazy that this this vibrant blue
it works for something natural selection
has has magnified this coloration not
all of them have have tongues this
vibrant but that is quite spectacular
there's a lot of different species of
the blue tongued skink and a lot of
different variations that breeders have
have come up with by mixing different
different subspecies and by just doing
selective breeding like you would with a
dog to get different colorations so this
is a really pretty version this is you
know I don't know if you'd call it an
albino but it's a it's missing all the
reddish pigment just really cool-looking
and here's here's a wild specimen doing
his threat display very intimidating
again I have no clue how what what
species finds that intimidating maybe
it's just other members of this species
that find it intimidating maybe there's
some sort of predator that's scared of
that too super super interesting anyway
back to the skink in question this is
the yellow-bellied three-toed skink and
in 2010 it was found that this is much
more interesting than anyone ever
thought before we found out that this
species
is a transition in transition between
egg-laying and giving live birth and
what they found is that the the
specimens and in a population on the
coast they will lay eggs and those eggs
take about 10 to 15 days to hatch so
they're actually pretty quick and in
there they hatch fairly quickly because
they're actually storing the eggs in
their bodies we found a second
population that hatches their eggs in
between 5 and 3 days so much much faster
and their egg shells are a lot softer
and they withhold their eggs inside the
body for a much longer period of time
and then we found a mountain population
and a much colder climate that actually
gives live birth their babies are born
live and after their babies are born
bits of membrane of eggshell membrane
very thin eggshell membrane are excreted
as well so this is a species in
transition from laying eggs to giving
live birth and we think that the the
selection pressure that's causing this
we think that the reason this is
happening is that this species is it's
up in the mountains and if you lay eggs
in a cold climate that those eggs have a
chance of freezing to death
not necessarily freezing in ice but just
the temperature being so cold that the
eggs are not viable and so this species
has been retaining retaining its eggs
longer and longer so that the the
embryos can be more and more developed
until finally you actually have live
birth happening with this particular
species of skank and so far as we know
they can all interbreed all these three
populations can interbreed with each
other and have viable offspring and one
one female was actually seen giving live
birth to several live babies and then
laying several eggs which hatched a few
days later so this is really a speech
in transition I find this absolutely
fascinating I mean that we think of live
birth and egg-laying as these completely
separate things but here we have a
species that can do both and it seems to
do both depending on the environmental
circumstances now there's a lot of
things we don't know about this we don't
know if if it could actually change its
behavior according to the climate so one
individual could lay eggs in a warm
climate and would retain those eggs in a
colder climate we don't know that we
don't know if it's a genetic tendency if
there's there's a an allele so a
different version of genes that cause
the egg-laying versus the live birth we
just we we don't know but it's super
fascinating to see this happening again
we have this this there's one
observation of a female giving both live
birth and laying eggs in the same in the
same batch of babies so super
interesting super weird misfit
evolutionary misfit living transition
between egg-laying and live birth and
you've probably noticed here that not
only is it weird and the fact that it it
does this live birth type thing but it
also it looks kind of like it's trying
to turn into a snake-like
organism and this is actually really
common in reptiles that live in leaf
litter and do a lot of or that do a lot
of burrowing that it if you are a
burrowing animal and you burrow in soft
soil so things like leave litter or sand
a lot of times you end up dating with
your face and your arms and legs sort of
become like a problem for you and we see
time and time again we see reptiles
going from a lizard-like body with very
strong robust arms and
transitioning into a snake-like
situation where you have very very small
arms and sometimes no arms and there's
actually a species of skank several
species of skank so here we have again
that this is the same this is the
three-toed skank from the top view and
you see it very very very small little
legs almost useless little legs and then
there is a species of skin called the
legless skank which is of course legless
and this thing completely just depends
on digging with its head and squirming
through loose soil and leaf litter very
much like a snake
super interesting this transition and
again you know we have the very lizard
like skank species this is the again the
the blue-tongued skink of Australia and
then we have the three-toed skank and
then we have the legless skank super
interesting to see these things so we've
got a couple questions we've got a again
if you have a question the best thing to
do is to is to write at stated casually
and and make sure you put a space in
there and then that will highlight it in
the live feed that I'm looking at as I'm
doing this presentation so I can see
your question why did egg-laying make it
through evolution eggs are always at the
danger at a danger of being eaten yeah
that is true
eggs are at a danger of being eaten
however there's lots of good ways to
hide eggs lots of ways to hide eggs a
lot of organisms will will excrete
things that that hide the scent of eggs
people organisms will bury eggs so
you've probably seen Turtles on the
beach sea turtles on the beach that are
burying their eggs it's actually pretty
rare for those eggs to be dug up
I need sometimes they'll see rock hands
go and dig them up but on a lot of the
islands that they choose they choose
places where they're not going to be dug
up
chickens and other animals of course
they guard their eggs and it's just a
lot it's all it is a lot more efficient
and in certain ways that they're
trade-offs right if you lay your eggs
you don't have to carry them anymore so
you can go out and get food if you're
hiding your eggs well you you can
actually just leave them alone which is
nice you don't have to even bother with
anything so sea turtles do that they
bury them and then they go off on them
right away if you are like a chicken you
can sit on your eggs and then go out and
feed and then go sit on your eggs and
then go out and feed and you don't have
to carry them around inside your body
which could be that could be a problem
especially if you're a bird and you need
to fly around having those eggs inside
of you is that's a lot of weight that's
there's a lot of reasons why eggs egg
laying is good everything's a trade-off
in evolution and it appears that these
these reptiles they've evolved these
this ability to give live birth and and
they retain their eggs
probably so that they can maintain
warmth that's that's what we think the
selection pressure is that's causing
this you know
reptiles of course are cold blooded but
when they move around they move their
muscles that heats up their body
temperature and of course they can they
can move into the Sun and keep
themselves warmer that way as well so
there's a lot of there's a lot of ways
that a cold blooded animal can keep
itself warm and we think that that's
what's happening here it's also possible
that the the real selection pressure
that's causing this this ability to to
give live birth in the skink maybe maybe
there's just more predators egg
predators in the mountain region than
there are in the coastal region and
scientist have been misled so they
thought it was the temperature but
actually it's a predation that that is a
possibility we actually have a lot of
different snake species and several
different reptiles that have evolved the
ability to give live birth and mainly
that's done by retaining their
so instead of having a full-on placenta
like like we do they just maintain their
eggs longer so that's kind of like the
poor man's live birth method it's just
that you actually do produce eggs but
you keep them inside of you and then you
release them later a poor man a poor
poor woman the it's it's the cheap easy
way to live birth see eggs contain a lot
of cholesterol and most species are
actually very healthy and tend to avoid
any eggs except for Saturday's the
traditional cheat day in nature that's
what joe de hack has to say here that
first question by the way about about
egg lane came from
gaurab Sharma hopefully I'm saying your
name right and Smith says they turned
off distal aminos and daya forus says so
bearing eggs are not caused by a random
mutation and because it worked it became
the norm for future generations and
reptilia well all of the changes that we
see I mean trying to say that everything
in evolution happens because of random
mutations is a little bit wrong the word
random is a little bit strange here
because there are lots of parts of the
genome that are protected from mutation
more than others so when we say that
mutation is purely random that's not
completely correct but yeah most most
evolutionary changes happen from what we
could call random mutations and by
random I mean there's no foresight the
the mutation isn't isn't caused with any
sort of knowledge of what the needs are
these mutations arise they cause
variations and traits and then those
traits are selected either for or
against and so yeah that that is that is
how egg-laying works egg-laying
is the more ancient trait giving live
birth is more complicated
keeping that egg inside your body as it
develops is more complicated than then
egg laying so that the live birth is a
new thing on the earth
most early organisms were actually
secreting eggs and sperm and those would
meet in the water so if you look at
sponges for example which are the most
primitive animals they're actually
excreting their eggs and their excreting
this sperm and the egg and sperm meet up
in in the open ocean and then the egg
starts to develop into an organism and a
lot of fish do that too it's it's it's
external fertilization so the fish will
spray out their eggs and the males will
spray out the sperm and the actual
fertilization happens in the water and
the the internal fertilization where the
egg is kept inside the body and is
fertilized inside the body that's new
that's evolutionarily new and then of
course keeping the letting that embryo
develop inside the body that's even
newer still and you know our ancestors
mammals come from reptilian ancestors
amniotes which were egg-laying organisms
and they could actually lay their eggs
on land this was a big a big significant
transition in the evolution of life on
earth is the ability to lay eggs that
are in water and that have to be in
water too being a little lay eggs on
land and this require the evolution of
what we call the amniotic sac which is a
sac inside the egg that helps prevent
water from leaking out of the egg and
that allows an egg to be laid on land
and so our ancient ancestors actually
laid eggs and there are still mammals
today that lay eggs the the platypus and
the there's another one that's really
just platypus that's the echidna those
both lay eggs still and they're kind of
leathery reptile like eggs and so yeah
that this transition from egg-laying to
live birth has happened many times
throughout evolutionary history oh look
someone's up ah
Ronna hopefully i'm saying your name
right asks why do platypus lay eggs even
as mammals are they transitioning
backwards no they're not transitioning
backwards they're actually a primitive
that they're actually using the
primitive version of reproduction in
mammals so we think that all mammals at
one time were egg layers then you have
the marsupials which they don't that
they gave birth extremely early and then
the it's really it's a fetus still when
it's born and it climbs into a pouch
where it's then nursed until it develops
which is totally weird and then you have
placental mammals that actually have a
placenta that nourishes the baby until
it's born and that placenta is it it's a
very complex structure and it it's it's
a we actually have an egg yolk at a
certain point in our development as well
we actually do have an egg yolk if you
look at human embryos and all placental
mammals we actually have an egg yolk
that we draw nutrition off of before the
placenta fully kicks in and giving us
our nutrients super interesting kind of
like a leftover remnant there did live
birth and mammals start with maintaining
eggs inside yeah we think so because we
actually still have this this we still
have an amniotic sac so we don't have we
don't have this this calcium eggshell or
this rough eggshell but that does not
exist at all in placental mammals but we
still do have the amniotic sac and we
still do have the egg yolk that develops
and that question came from shelled
reptile has the reverse tradition
ever happened that we know about so I
guess that would be from going from live
birth to egg-laying I actually don't
know I don't know if especially once
once you fully rid of the egg shell can
you gain it back again I don't know I
don't I don't know of any instance of
that happening but in this transition
then we're looking at right here with
the with the skank that could definitely
happen because some of them are still
laying eggs and giving live birth and so
if it became if the environment changed
to where selection pressure was favoring
the laying of eggs definitely this this
skank right here the the three totes
king that could definitely just go back
into full-on egg-laying and and you know
biologists in the distant future
wouldn't be able to tell this ever this
little transition ever happened at all
it would be completely invisible to them
so that's pretty interesting so this
brings us to that was our our misfit
number one of the day
nice beautiful transitional species and
again like this is kind of a what I call
my internet Safari
I like to go down these rabbit holes
sometimes where I just start reading
about animals and keep going going down
this pathway and this all got started
because I do presentations with high
schools and by the way if you are a high
school teacher and you want me to do a
presentation in your online classes
right now during kovat I'm happy to do
so
send me an email John at stated clearly
and we'll set that up but I had actually
done one in Seattle this last week just
through through well through zoom and
the students were asking me questions
about you know living transitions and
that got me I had prepared in advanced
started looking at this stuff and that
kind of started this me on this this
evolutionary online Safari that I went
down and then I'm sharing with you today
so it's it's pretty fun
so so well we got that we we kind of
covered this transition from egg-laying
to live birth we've we've covered this
transition of legless to non or sorry of
lagged reptile to legless reptile and
this probably happened in a similar way
with snakes we actually don't know if
snakes lost their legs because they were
burrowing or if they lost their legs
because they were aquatic sometimes it
happens to aquatic animals as well like
we've seen with whales whales have lost
their hind legs and so there's actually
some speculation and the fossil record
of snakes that snakes lost their legs
because they went marine for a brief
period you know nowadays we only have a
couple of different marine species of
snakes but we in the past there were a
lot more and we actually think that
might have been how they lost their legs
but that's actually up for debate it's
hard to tell in the fossil record in the
fossil record we have a lot of snakes
and you can tell a snake from a
different different types of reptiles by
their skull there's their skull
structures very different there they
don't have eyelids for example so that
the skink can blink its eye even though
it looks like a snake you can tell it's
not a snake because it blinks its eye
and there's a bunch of other little
anatomical clues that it's not a snake
if you open it up but yeah with snakes
were not sure if they lost their legs
from burrowing or from going marine but
anyway now we are going to look at a
really really interesting group of
animals called squat lobsters and squat
lobsters are interesting because they
gave rise to several weird animals that
were very some of which we're very
familiar with and some of which we only
learn about in 2005 so this is it this
is really fun to to think about so squat
lobsters there there are hundreds of
species of squat lobster and a squat
lobster they're called squat lobsters
because they're like lobsters but their
tails are small and lots of different
species from the
they look like this they usually have
their tail curled underneath so you
can't really see it and they kind of
look like crabs a lot of times people
will call them crabs but but they're
actually more closely related to
lobsters and you can see that in the
length of their you know antennae on the
on the front there and again like I said
there's many species here's one with its
tail out kind of looks a little bit like
Lobster a little bit more like a lobster
and here's one with a bigger bigger nose
and you know I don't know much about
this I've just I've it's been observing
this during my internet safaris but I
noticed that they have a lot of them
have this triangular shape on the top of
their their head that faces forward and
in some species it's very pronounced so
in this one it's like you know here we
have a series of spikes and here we have
those spikes are all fuse together to
form basically like a triangle on the
top of the head facing forward I think
that's really interesting and trying to
figure out why that is I mean why is
that has that evolved I have no clue but
it's just an interesting observation
I've been making and another interesting
observation that I've been making is
that all of these squat lobsters and
really is this is true of all deco pods
of all you know crabs and lobsters in
general is that they have a lot of hairs
on their arms
all of them have little hairs and they
have spikes and it seems like these
spikes that are on their arms evolve
into hairs in some situations and those
hairs are used to scents and those are
sensory organs the their nervous system
can pick up when those hairs are bent
and that's one of the ways that they
sense their their environment so they've
got an Tana but they've also got these
hairs on their claws and so on sorry I
get a little little sip of coffee here
so here's another species very they come
in every color squat lobsters are
amazing if you get online and start
looking them up there
it's spectacular what you're gonna find
there here's a really funny one extra
hairy on the arms there
and just bizarre coloration tiny little
guy here we see an even hairier squat
lobster still and this is called the
hairy squat lobster and again these
hairs are used as sensory organs and so
we have some that have spikes and we can
the spikes are used as defense when
they're really fine and bendable they're
used as sensory organs and so you have
what is called an evolutionary science
and exaptation so an organ that's being
used or a structure being used for one
thing is then used for a different thing
and a closely related species so most
parts of your body can be used for
multiple things you know your hands can
be used to fight a war or build a house
or comfort comfort a puppy and whatever
ends up being most useful for your
survival and reproduction natural
selection can actually exaggerate those
those aspects of an organ or a structure
over evolutionary time and and so in
this particular species of squat lobster
we see this exaggeration of this sensory
ability that that these spikes are able
to be used for so what what was probably
used as a defense mechanism in the past
is now being used as a sensory organ in
this particular species but if you think
this is crazy
with all of these hairs wait until you
see this guy this is the guy that was on
our thumbnail here and this is known as
the Yeti lobster and it was discovered
in 2005 sometimes it's called the Yeti
crab but 2005 it was discovered and this
thing lives at the bottom of the ocean
next to these sea vents and it uses its
hairs not just to sense its environment
not as a defense but it uses them
as a farm it is growing bacteria on
these hairs and then it will scrape its
arms so it does it does this it does
this motion where it puts its arms out
above event and it's actually it's
getting the the bacteria that live on it
or actually they eat the molecules that
are excreted from these events these
undersea vents so there remember how you
call this again there bacteria that they
don't use photosynthesis they don't they
don't eat other organisms they
metabolize these molecules that come out
of the the Earth's crust and so they're
yeah they're they just eat chemistry and
this this crab will put out its arms
over these these heat vents and allow
this bacteria to grow and then it will
scrape the bacteria off and it's got a
special mouth parts that help it do this
as well it'll scrape the bacteria off
and then it will eat those bacteria and
it actually makes its living by eating
the stuff that grows on its arm hairs
and this is just the most bizarre
bizarre way of making a living that I
have ever come across so this is the
yeti lobster and they they will eat
other things as well but I just just
just imagine the anxiety you must feel
waiting for enough stuff to grow on your
arm for you to scrape it off and eat it
you know you're getting hungry and you
got a decent colony going there but of
course with bacteria the more there are
the faster they reproduce and so there's
got to be a trade-off where there's a
there's enough to eat to to quench your
hunger but also if you eat them then
you're you're gonna hurt yourself in the
future because you're gonna stop their
ability to reproduce fast enough to give
you food in the future so that there
must be there must be this anxiety that
this crab feels about when
he should eat his his growing bacteria
and I just find this really fun to think
about like to them this is completely
normal and I the other thing that I've
been thinking about what with all these
weird organisms that I've been I've been
paying attention to lately I like to
think that what if it was this crab that
became the sentient being that invented
biology right and the study of organisms
they would think that they're the normal
thing and that everything else is weird
I mean just find that amusing and I find
it interesting ah Norio Cristino tells
me that it's it's called chemo synthetic
bacteria so yes thank you they're
they're metabolizing molecules in their
environment instead of actually
producing instead of eating other
organisms or using photosynthesis to
build sugar they're actually they're
using the chemistry of their environment
to synthesize eventually synthesize
sugars anyway what I seen is that I just
find this really fascinating and in a
lot of times we have this we have this
because we're humans and because we like
ourselves and we think a lot about
ourselves we like to think that we're
normal but we're not normal
we are just as weird as this crab where
we we are one species of primate that
somehow managed to invent biology and
think about our place in our ecosystems
and we think that we're normal because
we are so normal to ourselves right
we're it we're obsessed with ourselves
we're obsessed with interacting with
other humans but we are we really are as
bizarre as this Yeti crab it's just that
we we we don't realize this because
we're we're everything that we know
right
Tim Smith says it's evolution the most
successful species survives in their
environment yeah so back to my slides
here here is a group of these these Yeti
crabs Yeti lobsters hanging out and
their actual ecosystem you can see
actually that and when they're alive
they're a lot more decorated in hairs
all over their body in fact in the the
dead specimen here I think this is it
I'm pretty sure this is a dead specimen
this is the one that was collected a lot
of the hairs have been lost on its body
but in there or maybe it's just a
juvenile thing but in the end me this
photo here which was taken by a
submarine I think a robotic submarine
you can see they're actually very very
covered in hairs and they can probably
harvest from their whole body I would
imagine and there's also a species of
shrimp another thing to note here is
that they're completely white which is
abnormal for the squat lobsters in
general they're usually very colorful
but this this group is white and this is
true of all of the crustaceans that live
in the bottom of the ocean and that's
because there's no light there so
there's no reason for them to be
signalling to each other with color a
lot of the coloration that you see is
actually it's signaling so this specie
that the individuals are trying to
communicate with each other through
color and a lot of times you'll see in
the ocean you see brighter colors then
then you see typically on land and the
reason for that is that it's hard to
transmit color through the water it's
harder to transmit color through water
then through water then through air
because water is murky a lot of times
but obviously if you live at the bottom
of the ocean there's no reason to be
signalling visually because nobody can
see you it's dark and also there's no
there's no radiation that can affect and
damage your cells so you don't have to
protect your cells with pigments so
that's why organisms at the bottom of
the ocean don't bother even making
pigments making pigments is expensive
it's metabolically expensive so
organisms
the ability to make it over evolutionary
time daya forest says we are was as
bizarre as it gets we dead animals live
animals plants even bacteria that are
just as beneficial as the rest of our
food probiotics etc humans are bizarre
yeah and when you eat cheese you're
eating a bunch of dead bacteria and
actually we have bacteria in our guts
that are digesting a lot of our food
forests and we actually eat their feces
so a lot of a lot of our nutrients comes
from bacterial droppings even inside
your own intestines so yeah we are the
way that we get nutrients is super weird
super super weird alright so we learned
about squat lobsters and this this you
might think is a squat lobster with a
little bit of a longer tail and you're
actually sort of correct this is the
close relative to the squat lobster it
is called these are the pilo chilies and
there's a bunch of different species of
pile of chilies some people pronounce a
pile of killings and they're really cool
because they try to find shells or
sticks or bamboo to get inside of and
they spend almost all of their time
hiding inside of some sort of a
structure as you can see here this is a
female guarding her eggs with her tail
and inside of her structure and some of
them some of them are more adventurous
to go out on their own away from their
their hidey hole but a lot of them spend
almost all of their time inside the sea
shell that they find or inside of the
stick that they find and you're probably
aware there is another crustacean that
does this the hermit crab and check this
out here we have a Polly chalid next to
a hermit crab that does not have a shell
and you might be noticing that they are
insanely similar in their structure and
that is because they are extremely
closely related hermit crabs are a type
of squat lobster and there they are a
type of squat lobster that has developed
an obsession with finding shells in its
environment that they then hold on to
and hide inside of so here we have a
hermit crab this is the electric blue
legged hermit crab very common in
aquariums because they're really pretty
and people like them here it is outside
of its shell same species and you can
see that there their tail has been
dramatically modified over time well let
me just go back to it so Lobster is
another other and and and their
relatives have these little appendages
on the end of their tail you can
actually see that in the hermit crab
that those little appendages still exist
but they've lost all of their their
scales they're their armor on their tail
their tails are very soft I kind of like
they look like meat boogers they're very
gross looking and no not on all species
and some species they actually they're
actually colored and they actually are
really pretty but in this particular
species that looks very disgusting and
you also notice that it's it's it's
crooked it's not it doesn't bend
underneath like it does normally in
lobsters it bends to the side
and that's common and not all but many
species of hermit crab you know this one
here it actually curls underneath by the
way this species of hermit crab here is
actually it's called it's called a
blanket hermit crab because instead of
putting a shell on it actually puts on a
sea anemone around its abdomen and its
abdomen curls underneath and set it to
the side but so here we have one curving
to the side here is his what we call a
Halloween hermit crab because it's
orange and we're jerks
we name entire species after our
relatively new holidays but this thing
is super pretty
out of its shell here it is out of its
shell and it's interesting because I
actually don't so the the coloration on
its on its arms that is for signaling
its signaling to other members of its
own species that it exists and that it
is a member of the same species there's
lots of reasons that you want to signal
to other members of your species that
you are a member of the same species
this gives a lot of information to other
members of the species it tells them
that you're probably trying to eat the
same food that they eat so if you try to
live next to next to them you're gonna
have troubles with finding food because
they're already doing eating the same
thing you're eating there might be you
might be signaling sexual maturity so
that can help you signal for a mate
there's a bunch of different things you
could be signaling with these colors and
with most of these animals we don't know
what they're signaling we we just
haven't studied them well enough to know
what sorts of communication is happening
here but the reason that those are
colors like this evolve it's either for
camouflage or for signaling and in this
case we're quite certain that this is
for signaling these lobsters these squat
lobsters and hermit crabs they have
extremely good color vision they can
they're very they have very acute vision
and yeah they're they are communicating
with each other it's not clear to me and
then I have not been able to read
anything about this as to whether or not
that the tail here is has actually
evolved this color pattern so that it
can signal or if this is just the the
the patterning from the legs going on to
the tail because there's nothing
genetically causing it to stop so it's
just it just continues onward so that's
that would be something interesting to
study to do it to do research on and to
try and figure that out but we we don't
understand genetics well enough
to really understand those sorts of
things very well in the future we might
be able to figure this out but it's yeah
I I imagine it's not using its tail for
any sort of signaling because it's super
rare for these things to be outside of
their shell the only time they'll be
found outside of their shell is when
they're changing shells so when they
grow too big for that current shell
they'll exchange it for a bigger one
when they find one but it's uh yeah it's
it's possible that they actually come
out of their shells and signal to each
other but I haven't been able to find
any information on that super beautiful
animal here's just I'm just I went down
a rabbit hole and just started looking
at tons of different species of hermit
crab here they come in all colors these
are all marine species and marine
species again they're brighter in
general than land species not always but
in general and part of that is because
it's harder to signal to each other in
the water
here's another here's another guy this
is a I I really need we got orange and
blue and gray here super super
interesting and then this guy looks like
he's got got zits all over his body
pretty anything pretty cool just the
different ways that they've evolved to
signal to each other you know they're
I'm a member of your species come mate
or don't mess with me or you know
whatever it is that they're telling each
other it's really interesting and then
this I actually used to have one of
these I used to have an aquarium when I
was it when I was in high school I had a
saltwater aquarium and this is the I
can't remember what is called the people
who sold the to me called it a
strawberry hermit crab but it's it's
like a black spot a giant hermit I think
is what it's called something something
like that but they're really cool really
pretty animals have a couple questions
here in the comments
without bacteria I don't believe there
would be any plant or animal life due to
their sim symbiotic relationship what do
you think so I think you might be saying
that if if bacteria went extinct nothing
else could live
that's quite possibly true I think
actually well probably there are plants
that could live without bacteria but
almost all plants do you form some sort
of symbiosis with at least fungus but
yeah that'd be really interesting if all
bacteria went extinct what all life go
extinct actually probably so because
bacteria are the foundation of most
ecosystems so that's like the the bottom
of the food chain so you would have you
would have a huge cascade of extinctions
that's for sure Ann Smith asks are there
hair is the same as mammal hairs no on
crustaceans their hairs are just they're
extensions of their exoskeleton they're
very different structurally from from
mammal hairs which are cells that grow
from a follicle these do not grow from
follicles they develop underneath the
shell these hairs grow as the new shell
is growing and then when they molt the
hairs are really nice and find an impact
and they're really flexible and bendy
they start to wear down as time goes on
and so they shed their their exoskeleton
from time to time to re I guess
rejuvenate their hairs you could say so
that's very different than a mammals
hair that grows continuously from a
follicle from a follicle see
is the virus DNA found in our DNA
actually provides some perks to us are
they or are they just junk for us and
still helping the long-gone virus DNA
replication so this is a little bit of a
tangent our genomes are littered with
virus DNA and a lot of that DNA is
actually been incorporated into our
genomes and we're actually using we
actually use proteins from some of those
in some cases in other cases it's
basically just dead weight and our
genome so it actually depends a lot on
whether or not our ancestors have
co-opted those genes for their own
survival or not in the evolution of
placental mammals virus genes have been
co-opted to help us develop certain
proteins that are used in the placental
in the placenta and I it's been a while
since I read about this but I believe
there were there were also some genes
that are used to suppress the immune
system so the mother's immune system
does not attack the baby that I believe
I believe came from a virus originally
I'm not totally sure but I believe that
came from a virus so wait our genomes
once a gene gets inserted into an
organism's genome it can really end up
evolving to become a benefit to that
organism or it can just be dead weight
it it depends on a lot of different that
evolution is a mess it's an absolute
mess all right so here here I have a
handful of hermit crabs that I collected
from the Oregon coast and these species
are really interesting because they
can't they live in tide pools and they
live on the beach and they can come out
of the water to scavenge for food but
they can't stay out of the water very
long because they will dry out and when
their gills dry out they
but because they have these shells they
can fill those shells with water and
they can actually stay on land for a
long time before they dry out they carry
with them their own little packet of
water and that's really cool and here
the the the gills are actually found in
this part of the back here actually
underneath their shell they have the
gills here and if those drying out
they're dead but some species of hermit
crab have actually evolved really sturdy
gills and really really waterproof
exoskeletons and they can live for a
long time on land this is this is a
specimen from Ecuador when I was in
Ecuador and this guy these these guys
have gills that have been modified so
much that if they go into the water they
can actually drowned and it takes them a
long time they can actually spend a lot
of time underwater and a lot of time on
land but if they get too much water
inside of them they will actually
drowned they their their gills have been
adapted in a way that they carry water
inside their body those gills are inside
that water inside of their body but
there's so much more oxygen in the air
than there in the water that these gills
they've evolved to be more stiff so they
can they can handle a drier environment
but being more stiff means that they're
thicker and being thicker means that
they're not as efficient at pulling in
oxygen and so they need more oxygen in
order to work and in the water that they
like they will slowly suffocate drowning
might be the wrong word that little
slowly suffocate because there's not
enough oxygen in the water so they have
to come out of the water a lot and they
spend most of their time on land and
then you have species like this this is
a Caribbean species that really cannot
handle the water at all once it's an
adult so the juveniles are born in the
ocean they go through a larval stage
where they're fully marine then they
start coming out on land with their
juveniles and then they become fully
terrestrial when they're adults
and then you have the coconut crab which
starts out its life again in the ocean
then it becomes a hermit crab that needs
a shell and becomes a land hermit crab
and then it gets so big and so robust
that it actually gets rid of its shell
and it just lives as a shell this hermit
crab on land and these things are huge
it can be I'm like man I should have I
should have looked up how bad they are
but there there are pictures that these
will be like a garbage can a typical
size trash can not like not like when
you put outside your house for garbage
pickup but a true kitchen trash can
they're they're bigger than a kitchen
trash can there's there's photos of them
hanging out on garbage cans for size
comparison online so if you look at
these things they're the giant coconut
hermit crab and they no longer use their
shells for safety they just they just
use their own exoskeleton like a normal
crustacean does for protection there are
really cool animals and unfortunately
they're endangered because it tastes so
stinking good and it takes them years to
mature and so yeah they're they're going
extinct but really cool animals so we
we've really gone through a bunch of
different transitions here just by
looking at modern organisms we see this
crazy transition from we saw the the
squat lobster to the the hypothermia
vent squat lobster and we've seen squat
lobsters - hermit crab transition that
we have this this intermediate species
that doesn't always require a shell
you know it'll hide in sticks and so on
then we have hermit crabs some some
don't require shells some use a some use
sea anemones instead to protect
themselves and then we have those that
are obsessed with shells so obsessed
that they they're very anxious when they
don't have a shell and they're very
anxious when they're starting
get too big for their show and then you
have hermit crabs that have said you
know what screw this I don't want to
show anymore I'm just gonna be a giant
coconut crab and hang out on the on the
beach and in the forest and I also gave
up my my life in the water so it's it's
just really fun to see how all these
transitions happen throughout
evolutionary time and it's neat with
with crustaceans because there's so many
different species available still alive
today then we can actually we can
actually look at these transitions just
by looking at modern organisms we don't
have to go in the fossil record we can
go through the fossil record and find
these transitions happening there as
well but we don't have to I mean you can
actually still see there surviving
specimens that are still living these
ancient ways and they're living more
modern ways and super fun to just go
through and look at how this works so
here's here's a picture that I took in
Ecuador it was a hermit crab with a
shell hiding inside of a larger shell I
thought that was funny and that was
actually because I scared it and it ran
and it got inside that shell so it was
he was actually he was a little bit too
big to get inside of his own shell to
fully hide inside of his own shell and
this shell here that he's hiding inside
I was always the way too big for him to
use as his like go-to shell but he did
hide inside of it to get away from me I
thought that was funny okay last but not
least you know I'm I'm I've got a lot of
slides here I think I'm gonna go through
these a little bit faster but this this
animal is called a tongue fish this is
the D how do you say that Lac nur's
tongue sole fish and it's it's called
the tongue fish because it looks like a
tongue and sorry drink of water here up
close it looks like a chewed up tongue
with googly eyes stuck on to it
it's really funny that that there on the
side is its mouth here are its gills
it is a flatfish it's it's so you're
probably more familiar with you know
like flounders and halibut for flatfish
flatfish are the the weirdest fish I
like they're so bizarre their evolution
is super super strange they when you're
looking at a flatfish you're not looking
at its left side in its right side
you're actually looking at its dorsal
fin and its pectoral fin so this is
actually the the the cloaca is right
here right here these are the pelvic
fins here this is the pectoral fin and
so these fish are actually just sideways
they lay on they lay on one of their
sides
some species lay on the left side some
species lay on the right side and their
eyes actually migrate on their face as
they develop they look like Picasso
paintings these animals are hilarious to
me and here we see them the development
of a flatfish so they start out with
when they're really young they have an
eye on the left side and on the right
side of their body like a normal fish
then that eye starts to migrate to the
top of the head the the right eye in
this case and some species the left eye
and then it gets higher on the top of
the head and starts to go on to the left
side of the face until eventually you
get you get a flat fish a full-on
flatfish and here's another embryo and
development a little bit further in the
progression so his eyes are both on the
same side of its head and this just it
just completely distorts their face the
bones everything just shift around as
this happens during development during
develops re I'm getting a lot of my
voice is starting to crack here been
talking a lot
we see this in the fossil record this is
really neat
we can actually trace the evolution of
this in the fossil record a little bit
we have this species here of a very
early flatfish that has one head on the
top of its or one eye on the top of its
head and one eye on the left side of its
body and by the way we think that the
left and the right version species we
only think this evolved once we think
that there's a mutation that can
actually just cause the program the
developmental program to switch so you
get some species that are right
right-sided some species that are
left-sided it's not fully understood but
it seems to be that it seems like this
this weird annotation only happened once
and all the species we have today are
just variations of that but again just
like what we see in the fossil record is
what we see mimicked again in their
development you can actually see that
you know the there's a there's a there's
a point in development when they're very
similar to this this fossil species that
we find so that's really cool it's
really cool that we can actually see
embryology mimicking the fossil record
in this way and what this suggests is
that this evolved gradually over time
and and if it's not super hard to
imagine why this evolved you if you had
a fish that's laying on its side a lot
to hide from predators because they lay
on their side so they can hide in the
dirt and if you're doing that one of
your eyes is useless and so if you have
a mutation that makes your eye a little
bit higher on your head one of your eyes
kind of crawl up your face a little bit
you only have to to move your head a
little bit to use both your eyes to see
and that can help you get some depth
perception as you're trying to look
around at what's around you you're
trying to you you're trying to hide from
predators and hunt at the same time so
you can lift your head just a little bit
which doesn't reveal you in your place
very well but allows you to use both of
your eyes it's also probably slightly
dangerous to have one of your eyes
constantly shoved in the gravel you can
poke your eye on
then you can get a parasite more easily
that way so there's a lot of different
pressures that are gonna be in conflict
with the evolutionary pressure to hide
on your side and so these both of these
pressures could be could be causing
natural selection to favor any mutation
that causes that that bottom eye to move
upward and so that it doesn't have to be
in constant contact with the sand and
then eventually you would get the
eyeball on the top of your head so it
doesn't have to be on the sand at all
but then that kind of screws up your
death depth perception and then you get
it to actually migrate so that both of
the eyes are on the same side of your
face it's super weird this evolutionary
transition and it produces some of the
funniest looking fish that you will ever
see thank you this again this is a
Picasso nature's Picasso and there's so
many weird-looking ones
this guy's got this stupid looking nose
thing not really a nose but just but the
things that end up happening here are
bizarre and then this has got to be my
favorite this looks this thing looks
like it's in pain it looks like it's
suffering I'm being asked how is the
flatfish body useful evolutionarily they
can they can lay on the ground and they
look like the substrate I should have
had I should have got some pictures you
can kind of see in this picture
you see that the sand down here is it a
very same color and texture as its as
its skin that allows it to hide in the
sand it's it's these things are almost
invisible they're extremely hard to see
you you can swim right past a 500 pound
flounder or a halibut I think you can't
mind which ones get huge I think it's
the halibut that gets huge you can swim
right past one one that's bigger than
you and you will not see it because it's
hiding on the ground it there they are
amazingly good at camouflaging and this
is because they're they're big and flat
and you know you can imagine there's
there's two ways that this could have
evolved you could have had just a normal
fish
get flatter and flatter but height wise
but fish in general are tall and skinny
and so the ancestor of the flounder was
tall and skinny and instead of evolving
to become flat it would just lay on its
side to hide from predators and it's
just that habit of hiding outside was so
useful that this weird adaptation of the
eye migrating to the other side of the
face ended up evolving because evolution
is is weird it just it takes what you
got
you're always working with what you
currently have and if there's consistent
selection pressure to keep doing
something weird evolution will actually
pull you to it'll transform your body to
make it easier and easier to do that
weird thing that you were doing you know
from generation to generation super
bizarre how evolution works and then of
course the weirdest of all in my opinion
is the tongue fish it looks like a
chewed up tongue so anyway oh there you
have it folks
that is my internet Safari thank you for
joining me on this Internet Safari to
explore the evolutionary myth misfits
the living evolutionary transitions that
exists today so I guess they did it for
the halibut
classic classic dad joke there
so at the start of the show for those
who who came late I asked a question how
many species do you think are inside of
a chocolate chip cookie and it's a weird
thing to think of because we don't
normally think of a chocolate chip
cookie is having species in it at all
but a typical chocolate chip cookie
actually has multiple species in it and
this is the this is a
this is an actual cookie that I made
this week I actually took a picture of
my own cookie so I can make this slide
but the ingredients of this were sugar
white sugar brown sugar flour eggs
butter chocolate chips baking soda and
salt and if you add that all up and if
you figure out how many different
species are in a chocolate chip cookie
turns out that there are what five
species you've got sugar cane which is
the type of grass you've got wheat which
is a type of grass you've got eggs so
you've got chicken in there you've got
butter which of course is made of milk
which comes from a cow and you have the
cacao plant the seeds of the cacao plant
which make the chocolate inside the
chocolate chips so when you need a
chocolate chip cookie you are eating a
huge diversity of organisms from a
really wide spread on the evolutionary
tree
so anyway I'm gonna I'm gonna close
things off here but if anyone has any
last-minute questions or comments please
do write at space stated casually and
also I'll make sure to see that but
again there's a little bit of a delay
between this broadcast there's a delay
here so type your questions quickly or
else I'm gonna miss them one question is
do species steal good evolution ideas
from each other I guess you could say
that that's some deal and the fact that
there is some some cross species gene
swapping there's horizontal gene
swapping from time to time so I spoke
earlier about viral genes being used in
the placenta and so yeah we do get we do
get genes from other organisms but we we
don't steal ideas so you cannot will
yourself till we evolve a new trait well
I guess you can in the fact that you can
invent technology so once your brain
gets
you can certain venting tools then you
can definitely steal adaptations from
other organisms we still adaptations all
the time
a lot of our inventions are are based on
stuff we learned from animals so that's
one way to do it our species does steal
good evolutionary ideas from other
species but as far as genetic evolution
goes instead of cultural evolution and
technological innovation you can't a
species can't just look at another
species and be like I want that that's
not how it works
descent with modification you have these
what you what you can think of as random
variations and that there's there's
there's no foresight in a variation
these things are just selected for after
after they appear they are either
selected for or against and that's how
evolution works
how do marsupials fit into the
transition between egg-laying animals
and placental mammals I don't know
enough about that to really give an
intelligent response so I'm just going
to go ahead and not respond to that but
that is an interesting question
I think platypus fits that so the
platypus is the platypus is a primitive
version of they have a primitive
reproductive method so the platypus is
laying eggs still and it does that
because all of our ancestors at one time
laid eggs all the ancestor of all
mammals was an egg-laying organism we
think and we think that from genetic
analysis and really the position of
platypuses and echidnas on the
evolutionary tree we think that they
represent a primitive version of
reproduction now of course whenever
we're whenever we're looking at modern
animals sorry whatever we're looking at
modern animals to try and figure out the
what our ancestors were like we can't
just
map on what what platypuses are doing
and say that's how mammals used to do
right because the platypus has been
evolving the same amount of time as
placental mammals since since the split
between platypi platypi or platypuses
since the split between the platypus and
the rest of mammals both lineages have
been evolving for the same amount of
time and so we can assume that they're
dramatically different now than than the
ancestor was but what happens a lot of
time in evolution is that something that
works well will just keep working and
won't be changed that much in one
environment and then in some other
environment it will not work very well
and so it will undergo a rapid
evolutionary change rapid
when I say rapid I mean millions of
years but you know faster than the other
lineage that's not under this new weird
selection pressure and so we can be
fairly confident that the platypus
reproduction reproductive method still
does represent something similar to the
ancestral form that our joint ancestors
were using if that makes sense
diego asked walrus evolution why do they
make all those weird noises I don't know
I don't know why Waller says make weird
noises it's some sort some form of
communication
just imagine humans laying eggs we are
seven plus billion now we would have
been way way more than that if it didn't
take that long for a human to grow up
inside its mother's belly what a
nightmare
I don't know if that's true because well
humans do a lot of developing we do a
lot of developing before we're born
which I think you would have to do
inside of an egg which means you'd have
to produce a huge huge yolk so having a
placenta is cool because it allows the
mother to keep giving nourishment
instead of having to produce a giant
yolk so yeah that's interesting would we
would egg-laying work yeah yet the
trade-offs here are just it's really
hard to think about and it's really hard
because what's good in one situation
depends on a bunch of things including
environmental pressures but also just
your own evolutionary history
what is your species currently good at
doing and what are the pressures in the
environment and it's really hard to it's
really really hard to to predict where
evolutions going ahead and this it's
really hard to say that one thing is
actually better than another thing
because everything is so dependent on
context but yeah
let's see
looks like that's all the questions here
I'm getting a couple more how does DNA
comparison
how is DNA comparison and evidence for
evolution by comparing DNA you can you
can you can tell who's more closely
related to who and you can see how
different proteins evolved and how
different you can see that certain genes
are turned off so there's a bunch of egg
producing genes in map and placental
mammals that are just turned off now and
so that's that's evidence that our
ancestors used to lay eggs and then we
see that confirmed in the fossil record
so DNA evidence is a really strong
second record aside from comparative
anatomy and aside from the fossil record
it is a very it is a completely
different line of evidence that tells us
the same story that we are all related
and we can see these relationships and
sequences of DNA all right well I think
I'm going to end it there this is a this
has been a fun day this has been a fun
conversation hope you enjoyed it and
next week I hope to have on a guest to
talk about the philosophy of science
what is a theory what is a hypothesis
and how did different philosophers of
science think about those things
differently and think about the whole
this thing that we call science
differently so that's gonna be fun so
I'm telling that